What are your thoughts on chlorine dioxide detox?
I have several videos on these before that I've answered this question multiple times.
This question always gets us in trouble.
So we won't be able to post this video on YouTube or they will literally shut down our channel.
It's funny how they can scan with AI and find video on chlorine dioxide
that some little teeny pukey, a little clinic hosted on their teeny little YouTube channel.
And they'll find it within an hour and they'll block our channel.
But they can't stop pornography.
It just literally blows my mind the evil that's in this world.
But such is the case.
What are my thoughts on chlorine dioxide detox?
Well, there's much said and much promised with chlorine dioxide in that chlorine dioxide.
Circles, Dr. Jim Humble, what MMS on the map years ago.
And although I think there's much benefit to it when we used to treat line patients,
we used MMS all the time.
I think it can be extremely beneficial to kill pathogens that are difficult to kill.
It has side effects, but I also think it is way over hyped.
And quite honestly between you and me, I think Dr. Jim Humble was a sort of a snake oil salesman.
So when you start claiming that something is the panacea of all disease,
I think you're frigid on that as a label on your coat.
Because it's just, it's just not true.
Chlorid dioxide can be toxic.
It can cause toxic issues.
It can cause inflammation.
It can cause damage to two tissues.
Certainly can cause oxidative stress, which not necessarily isn't necessarily a bad thing with cancer patients.
But it doesn't spare healthy cells.
Whereas, okay, so we're trying to increase oxidative stress with the cancer patient.
Let's say we're using high dose curcumin.
That's an example.
High dose curcumin will cause oxidative stress to cancer cells,
and thereby help tip them over and cause death to a cancer cell.
But it does not cause oxidative stress to a healthy cell.
It spares healthy cells.
Versus chemotherapy causes oxidative stress to cancer cells and can kill cancer cell.
But does not spare healthy cells and can cause cancer elsewhere in the body and can kill other cells.
So you have to be careful in the dosage so you don't kill the patient before you kill the cancer.
Same thing with chlorine dioxide.
It is a drug.
It's not a natural supplement.
So it doesn't spare healthy cells.
So I am not a fan of using chlorine dioxide with cancer.
But by a fan of using chlorine dioxide with Lyme disease, sure,
it can be extremely beneficial, but you have to go slow with it.